era el último héroe francés del
desembarco de normandía el presidente
francés Manuel ardió homenaje a leogoche
que falleció el lunes con 100 años lo
describió como una persona dispuesta a
sacrificar su vida para los demás
León fue uno de esos franceses
corrientes decididos a lograr lo
extraordinario encarnaba el espíritu de
resistencia tan francés y en el fondo
tan republicano
con solo 17 años se unió al general de
Gol en Londres en 1940 para seguir el
combate después de que Francia firmara
la amnistía con Alemania y el 6 de junio
de 1944 junto con el comando
en la costa de normandía para liberar
Francia de la ocupación nazi con sus
compañeros habían decidido que no
volverían a embarcar y que lucharían
hasta el final
hubo un alboroto Terrible desembarcamos
y corrimos en la playa lo más rápido
posible para no exponernos al Fortín que
intentaba dispararnos
todos mis compañeros y yo hubiéramos
preferido morirnos a dar Un paso atrás
el homenaje es eso en forma de honores
militares un sueño para leongoshí que
siempre recordaba que al lado de los
batallones norteamericanos también
estaban los británicos polacos y
franceses en los últimos 30 años el
veterano se había instalado en wish
normandía donde trabajaba para
transmitir la memoria de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial